maybe he was coming to collect me he
wanted me to join him or hold his hand
or wipe his butt for him i'm good at
that professional butt wiper before i
did youtube let's
what see that
okay it's awfully
okay bright right
give me something give me something oh
my god
oh crap i'm going to
die that was
this was a dumb idea
hi where'd you come from whoa
what is wrong with your face
oh i should have opened this before i
got here open you damn it
oh it was right there it was right there
oh my god
oh where did i go ah
where is is that him ah tim
oh don't come in here oh oh oh sticking
ever so quietly you're big
ain't you you're a big boy oh my god
oh you're weird get away
i got it i ain't got an itch you're so
weird
you're so weird get away from me you're
so weird
oh you're so weird oh you're so funny
hi can you not can you not can you not
can you not how about you go over the
edge i'm gonna send you flying over
these whoosh
goodbye have fun with that guy
oh god oh god i'll go all in oh no
oh no oh no oh where do i go
oh come at me bro
epic dodge epic doge
i heard that
i hear that that's the thing
that's a second oh that's the thing oh
there's something over there
no no no no no no no no no
ha ha
yeah suck on that big fat douche
little piggy little piggy no no go home
little piggy no bother me
i'm piggy little piggy you gotta go on
free wait i hear him where is he
where is he hide right there ah
little piggy no no little piggy go home
don't get me i'm a little piggy little
piggy not here little piggy go go what
was that
now i better get back to my biscuits and
gravy
i'm really hungry cleaning up this
entire hospital
ripping the heads off of people is a
hard job but somebody's got to do it
who is my teddy bear i want to give him
a nice big hug
i would never rip the head off of my
little teddy bear oh is that is someone
making fun of me over there
so it might be a problem
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
gotta hurry through here before i
actually do run out i knew i was
ah everybody i'm sorry
pray for revelation
if you say so okay gonna close the door
bye-bye
okay oh my god
the naked twins what it's a privacy but
there was a leap of faith to be
where am i where am i oh my god oh my
god no no no no no
ow owie hey come on me bro
come at me bro
wow okay i couldn't close that okay
couldn't do it just bam
oh son of a [ __ ]
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh what now but now you big ugly brute
thanks for watching my outlast reaction
compilation
if you like this video and you want to
see more then please click that
subscribe button
if you're already subscribed then please
take a moment to share this video with
your friends
it took a lot of work and your help will
go a long way for the channel
thanks again everyone for watching and
as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye